live on periscope - this is our very
first star talk cosmic query is live on
Facebook and I got with me Chuck nice
Jack I've got a couple minutes together
here yes we do yes we do this yeah it's
great and we are going to get to
questions once people get online once
they know that we're here and they
poeple online three queries this is a
normal thing we do on star talk radio
absolutely and people so people typing
in right now people are typing them
right now and they'll just still make
their little replies and their comments
and as they come through I will give
them to you okay and you can add the
meantime I just talk smack right in the
meantime and normally you know normally
what happens is we we filter these
questions yeah so or I've talked to them
the cool thing about this is I have no
idea where anybody is going to ask and
whatever comes through so whatever you
want to know bring it on bring it on
let's go ahead make my day so and before
we do that I should also let you know
that for those of you who are interested
you know everything that we do no matter
what it is we have now a site called
Startalk all-access comm which is a
subscription site where you can
subscribe everything we do you'll
receive commercial free in addition to
that you'll receive videos of all the
podcasts that we do in addition to that
there are interviews that you do Neil
with very famous people that never make
it to anywhere they're on the cutting
room floor and we'll have goes there and
in addition to that if that is not
enough you we also have exclusive
original content that can only be found
on all access and when you subscribe if
that is not enough you can watch this on
Apple TV Amazon fire and Roku and you
get again - nice but wait if you ask now
all right so what do you have data
coming in yet let's see here I have not
where this is potpourri so this is on
any soft topic in the universe and if I
don't know the answer
I'd only answer I'll just say I don't
know go on to the next question okay so
here's the deal you know everything I
have stuff about the universe cool thing
is I have three hundred four hundred and
some-odd people on here right now
okay and I just pulled up the comments
let's go sure I'm not even going to
pronounce your name perfect Avanza comma
mama kuru say any advances in the field
of interstellar travel as we have
discovered seven new exoplanets yeah so
he want you what you want to leave her
he wants it out of here like I gotta get
out of here now I heard Goldilocks zone
and I'm like I'm ready to go well so the
problem is the fastest spaceship we've
ever launched the fastest thing if you
aimed it for the closest exoplanet can
get the other seven right go to Proxima
Centuri
it's called Proxima my beer is closed
right the closest is why this we gave
get gave it that name it's four
light-years away oh the other one is
what is it 40 50 light-years I forgot
the number but it's tens of light you to
Proxima Centuri right there aim your
fastest thing we have ever launched take
you seventy thousand years let's go
tomorrow so you got to figure out how to
defy your biology right or invent a
wormhole and I'm gonna I'm gonna bet on
the wormhole okay not cryostasis now and
then make a movie and a cup we wake up
seventy thousand years later this guy
and you know of course there's a thing
you only have a five o'clock shadow some
reason in the movies go to sleep for
seventy thousand week I might need this
that's not the only issue in the movie
they never pee or poop and moving
exactly right there are other issues
there are other allottee right all right
what else you got hi here we go let's
let's move down and see what we got
interesting here how about dr. Tyson
this is a deep deep in swig kiya how
about dr. kite I'm so sorry for
butchering your name I know I did
uh hello dr. Keiser came gonna bring a
name reader and then you pick up the
question after okay lord and lady font
okay
dr. Tyson can you talk about the
articles you've written that have
appeared in any peer review journals
along those lines
yeah sure you have yeah yeah I have a
not as many as many of my colleagues do
that exclusively um but I had a
prediction some years ago published in
the Astrophysical Journal Letters right
which are shorter faster communication
that might have impact to affect the
work of others I made a prediction that
there might be 10 times as many galaxies
out there now and what our van catalogs
would show right and at the time some
better telescopes were brought to bear
on it and they found like three or four
times as many galaxies yes the full up
to a two full ten still feel good it
prompted two searches and and and a way
to find them there and recent evidence
actually comes much closer to my
original prediction so I feel pretty
good about that one example of stuff
that I done but if it's not secret
publications there's something called
Google Scholar okay it's not your normal
Google search engine but just type in
Google Scholar go there and type in my
name and you'll see all mine you'll see
yourself that's very cool
there you have it all right also study
the structure of the Milky Way galaxy oh
well in the core in the center and
things like that so it's in there if
you're at the core of the connector of
the Milky Way if I'm not black hole
lurking there yes oh no I thought it was
caramel and creamy nougat okay next okay
I couldn't help it man I'm side there
you go
lightning round because we are much time
I have a lot of time dr. Tyson I want to
do exactly what you do what did you
study to be where you are right now it's
study physics and math both of which
constitute the language of the universe
okay in the same way you want you to go
to China you learn Mandarin you speak to
people there and you weren't Spanish to
go to Spain you speak to people there
right you want to speak to the universe
and understand what it's telling you
right speak its language and that's math
it's math and physics basically the
foundations of the sciences and so
that's what I did so I majored in
physics sweet in college and then got a
PhD in astrophysics and then you are
conversant then
and but I do these others I write books
and this sort of thing so I think a lot
about how people learn and how they pay
attention and so I fold in what I know
with what it is to share that love then
I'm just doing what Carl Sagan said you
do when you're in love you want to tell
the world
oh all right hey Chauncey Heath Chauncey
first of all what's up and secondly he
says dr. Tyson Moon or Mars oh I mean
that's I love that because the whole
question is implicit in those two hey
you guys where you want to go first
there you go the margins on the moon go
to Mars what it's harder and do you have
the money can you do it yet can we do
the moon first and you can do that in a
new cycle because it only takes three
days to go to the moon you hang out come
back you're back in a week
Mars is years so I'm saying I'm I'm a
contrarian here not country I have I'm
driving in a different Lane okay my lane
is we should turn the whole solar system
into our backyard with a lineup of
booster rockets and take two from here
three from there that gets you to Mars
right one from there two from there that
gets you to an asteroid right wait we
should not be thinking of destinations
we should be thinking of capabilities
Wow
and if you think of capabilities as a
goal in the entire solar system becomes
your backyard and nothing sits out of
reach hot damn that was good haha mic
drop
alright let's move on to do doo doo doo
doo doo doo sorry here we go I wanted to
get this one purpose purposely Raul NAR
juanny okay Raul says this putting co2
back into the earth in pressurized
condition after absorption is this
feasible what we talked about carbon
capture is here car yeah they call it X
carbon capture exactly is it is it
feasible yeah so I it turns out from
what I have read if you want to remove
carbon from the air that we have put in
the energy requirement to do that you're
gonna ask we're gonna get the energy to
that make sense right and if you're
doing it you know you're going to burn
oil to capture the carbon right so if
you're doing it with so
or power or something that does not have
a carbon footprint that you could have
used that for your energy in the first
place that's right why you right so so
these are some of the challenges the you
know that will confront us
as we move forward it'd be great if we
can have some way to just dump the stuff
back into the back into the ground the
limestone is sequestered carbon
basically right and so but that involve
life forming it so if you could do that
yeah burn away you know burn baby burn
bury it but with areas we're not there
yet we're not that would know you don't
have that much power over geoengineering
to turn that into a thing
so really the better solution is
switching then trying to deal with
continuing to burn and burn it's like oh
what's the solution to acid rain let's
all perish let's all grab Monroe Braille
is right let's all code everything in an
epic gruesome
lair of some type of yeah this depends
on how you're thinking about solving a
problem right that's all okay gotcha
this is a Rizzo band dorita a Rizzo band
ELISA says good evening dr. Tyson is
there aiming time so he's here he's in a
different time time zone somewhere
evenings rad so that would be Europe or
yeah they're over okay there you go
so Rizal there's only three o'clock in
the afternoon there you go so Rizal says
this good evening dr. Tyson is there any
plan for a cosmos season two mmm-hmm
well we're trying to get the band back
together for that right and it was a
huge collaboration art you know artists
and designers and right you know and so
so nothing's greenlit but we're trying
to lean that way so there's nothing to
announce yet okay cool thank you for
that question the great question that
they liked they loved the first one that
means they want more
hey cold przemo cold yes I did make a
dad joke I apologize
here we go whoo oh oh okay so Ally Yaya
Yaya wants to know this can humans
develop to be higher and smarter
creatures and we developed that so I
don't see why not
in principle it's just that the brain
remains such a mystery to us we don't
really have a good explanation for
consciousness much less what's going on
in your brain for it to become
intelligent right we know what can make
you really not intelligent okay so true
good almost any chemical influence on
the brain makes you sort of less capable
than other than no influence on the
brain okay when you things like alcohol
and drugs and things that people people
do under those influences that's not
when you want to write down the rocket
formula right so so in this I would say
there could be a day where we find out
that these neural synapses are your
analytic Center and this is where your
math Center is and this is where your
artistic Center is and I want to be a
better artist well stimulate that or
rebuild this I don't see anything in
principle from standing in the way of
that ultimately being discovered one day
unless intelligence is so complex soap
is so distributed in all the neural
synapses that it's hard to just point to
it we can't can't locate localize it
localize it it could be something much
more intricate than how I'm making it
sound at this moment but sure you'd want
it you'd want that to happen and then
there's all we can become better
shepherds of our own fate because
there's also the integration of
technology into the human brain that may
be the next evolution of who we become
or why you have to put it in the brain
just leave it out here all right no I
mean come over my brain all right you're
right stop messing with my brain
stay on the phone damn right people stay
on the phone you don't say one day will
plug their USB into your neck and I'm
saying this is kind of already that
right right but it's not plugged into my
neck right and get knowledge from the
world
all right here Oh in the palm of your
hand I got Nick alone I taste them cook
says this hey dr. Tyson have you ever
worked with or been to the Hadron
Collider I have never been to you got to
watch how you pronounce that because
let's take horror goes in the wrong
place let's say hard-on Collider so I'm
saying it's just hard when we divide a
place where yeah okay I I deeply regret
that I've yet to visit the the European
Center for Nuclear Research which is
acronym doubt its iron
and their biggest accelerator there is
the Large Hadron Hadron Collider and
hadrons or particles made of quarks and
the general description of particles
made of quarks and so basically they can
slant protons together make very high
energy environments and they're looking
for dark matter and it's basically the
largest machine ever built okay
it's my largest machine ever built
period ever
Wow next is like the International Space
Station Wow you can say that's built
like in space International Space
Station is the size of a football arena
right let the Large Hadron Collider is
like miles in circumference look at that
go there just stand there look at photos
of people standing in the cross-section
of the collider you see the wires and
the metal and it's superconducting and
it's got its physics and so you say whoa
we can do this we can probe I bet the
Big Bang itself giving us a little taste
of the origin of the universe in our
backyard
laughter the physicists and last
question from Yasha bompa Yasha Vantaa
who says hey dr. Tyson I'm from India
please will you run for president India
what something I'm pretty sure he means
here yeah no but that'd be pretty funny
it's just like will you run for
president of India is that a he or she
yeah I don't know Chalmers named Yasha
vantaa Joseph um sir I said I'm sorry I
think you're free no I don't know I
don't know okay but so I know I actually
on my website I have I was asked by the
I was asked by the New York Times back
when Congress was at an impasse and they
said let's ask people who are not
politicians if they have solutions to
this because clearly the politicians
don't okay so they asked like a musician
and it's and I'm like the scientist they
asked and I and so the question is what
would you do if you were president and
my answer was and is and still is posted
on my website not my Facebook page I
actually have a website that's an
old-fashioned I am that's it what if I
were president this is what things would
be and in there it says if our president
I would not be President
I have I don't have interest in leading
people right I interest as an educator
and especially as a scientist is
educating people right so that they can
make as an informed decision as they can
when they elect who they want to
represent them nice you just went around
swapping leaders back and forth you
haven't solved the electorate problem
Wow okay so the real problem with
America is we are too dumb the pit good
leader no no no no no let me say
differently okay
the problem is if we have this if we
have dysfunctional politicians right
it's because we have a dysfunctional
electorate right the electorate puts
them in office hmm and if you say I hate
this guy better then vote him out right
hey you vote for these people in a
democracy in India the world's largest
democracy all right
yes we can control this stuff it's not
some King brought down from the ages
where you can't get rid of him and in
the old days the only way they got rid
of him was how off with your head off
with your head okay so so so I'm just
saying I would rather I would rather
disseminate knowledge wisdom and insight
to all who I can so that when they make
their political decision whoever they
vote for which has informed the decision
as they possibly can make Wow that is
good good stuff we are out of time and I
hate Joel and Gabriel and ally and
Nimrod and so know me we couldn't have
gotten all the core Leonard and Carol
and Josh and you guys have some great
questions but they're very involved and
you know I'm just worried
and why I'm sorry to bust in your day
this way right but you know what we're
going to get all this stuff on a regular
start off because this we're going to
keep these critical answers and those
questions we're going to keep this we're
going to keep those questions you a
whole star talked to a star talk just
off to the queries that you guys have
here that's great for nuclear cosmic
queries and of course everything that we
do can be found commercial-free along
with exclusive original content on
starts off all access com stuff
you see Neil do that he won't do
anywhere else like get naked there's not
no don't let that one female naked not
read more don't you want to see me I'll
make them mad mad so I talk all access
calm I'm gonna make it no that's a step
start talk after hours alright we out we
out okay